we're talking about
when women treat pets like kids
this happens a lot i've had this uh sent
to me quite a bit
in bumble and tinder profile screen
captures
uh i've seen this a few times i did a um
a poll which i'm gonna share
uh in just a minute on the screen uh
guys again if you're watching this
somewhere else do me a solid come on
over to um
youtube and watch it over here uh so if
you're on twitter facebook
hit that link come on over to uh youtube
it helps me out a ton
and smash the like button like that that
little thumbs up
okay let's get started um let's let's
hop into this poll
now i want to say this before some
people freak out i
am not opposed to pets i happen to like
dogs i had a dog at one point
uh she was a sweetheart but um sometimes
women go a little bit overboard i think
dogs are great especially for men
there's a reason why they call it you
know men's best friends
uh if you want something that's gonna
love you unconditionally if you want
something that's that's
actually gonna love you more than it
loves itself get a dog
uh don't go looking for a wife or a
girlfriend just get a dog that that'll
that'll tick off that box
100 of the time problem that i've seen
those a lot of the times women get a
little stir crazy when it comes to
pets somebody said the other day if she
gets a small
dog she's trying to replace children if
she gets a big dog she's trying to
replace
a man i got some cool stories to share
tonight too on uh
some of these let me just pull this up
on the screen and show you the poll
results
share screen app window
boom boom boom all right so you guys
probably
see this from time to time but there's a
community tab
and there's um you know stuff that i
post on there sometimes it's question
surveys
by the way if you haven't seen this um
bit here that i posted the other day
sean stevenson did a talk
on the prison of your mind lesson number
one never believe that
any prediction that doesn't empower you
go watch that after this video i also
did an interview with him which i linked
over here
it is definitely worth your while to
watch that uh he passed away a few
months later but
let's move down to the pet thing here so
we stay on topic for the whole night
here
um okay here it is men only what is your
policy on
dating women dog cat moms with pets on a
longer term basis
so when i'm specifying this what's your
policy on dating women with pets on a
long term basis more than
spinning a plate more than going out on
a couple of dates i'm talking like
you're gonna see her on a more long-term
basis like three six months plus
okay generally i found women with pets
have gross habits like letting animals
sleep in her bed
in many cases they treat them like
children and it's similar to being with
a single mom only her kids
crap on your floors um
i did not know what to expect when i
started dating chicks
uh with pets you know because they'd
have their own place and for whatever
reason they always seem to have a pet
or more than one pet i remember when i
was working
in the credit collection world i was
about 22 or
3 and walking around the office
i noticed this bizarre trend with uh the
ladies
over in the skiptracing department
because
by a wide margin the men were always for
the most part doing the collection work
and making all the calls
and they had a skip trace apartment
which basically tries to locate people
and you walk through there and they were
mostly older
older-ish type of type of women and they
often had picture frames on their desks
with
around christmas time pictures of them
and their pet
sometimes pets on santa's lap
and i thought it was a little bit weird
i'm not gonna lie
i thought it was a little bit crazy i
think i might have said a comment or
made a comment at one point
uh if i'm not mistaken i probably had a
phone call or an email from an
hr clerk on it but it's a little bit
bizarre when it goes to that level
um listen i like i like dogs you know
here i'll pull
up uh there it is that was my pup that
was uh
she was about i don't know 75 80 pound
rottie um i didn't have her for two too
long but uh
i was about 21 22 at the time um so
dogs are a sweet little thing um so the
poll results here we got 35
000 votes back and
the 50 of the votes went to i'm okay
with women with one pet
after that it's too much uh the second
highest uh item selected was i'm ju i
generally avoid
women with pets and long-term
relationships but will smash
and then i went down to i'm okay with a
woman with two plus pets
doesn't phase me at all and
i'm a woman i just want to see the
results so i always put that there just
so somebody can try to click it through
if they want to see the poll results and
not skew the results
so the thing that you gotta that you
gotta understand here guys is when
you're gonna mess with chicks
with pets a lot of them have
unhealthy relationships and attachments
to them
i remember i remember this one girl i
dated in my 20s
she had this i don't know what kind of
cat it was but she had two cats
so when i first started dating her you
know you stay over
and the stupid thing would bite your
feet while you're sleeping and i'm not
talking like
a kiss or a nibble or a lick it would be
like a full-on
chomp down on your toe while you're fast
asleep
well it was either me or the cat i told
her the cat went you know flying across
the room did it a few more times anyway
she got rid of that cat
the other one was like a bowlegged one
whose legs were like caving in because
it was so
fat its belly would like drag on the
ground i don't know what it is with fat
house cats
with women with these things but they
just like lie there with these big fat
bellies and they're like wow and they
just drag on the ground behind them
this thing i don't know where to get
started with this cat
situation again i like i'm not opposed
to pets i like
animals like i said before look if you
you know if you want something that's
going to truly
love you unconditionally get a dog it's
the only thing that will actually love
you more than it loves itself even your
mom
cannot love you as much as a dog will
love you
that's just reality of it don't go
getting married don't get don't go
getting a girlfriend if you want to be
loved by something get a dog it will
love you more than it loves itself
that's just the way that it is
all right let's see what we got here
let's keep on
chiming through because we got some
comments
based off that let's add us back to the
stream here
okay so let's see what the top comment
was here ryan says i'm okay with women
having as many pets as she wants as long
as she takes care of them
and her house doesn't smell like an
animal shelter can't stand dogs sleeping
on
bed there's there's two important things
here so
animal shelter another chick i dated
once
so we go back to her place and of course
you know why we go back there because
stuff has to get done but walk into her
apartment and i swear to god it was like
a wall of
i don't even know how to describe it
there's like a wall of a scent of
feces and urine just like slapping you
across the face
hard and then you walk in there and
you're like what's going on in here
she's like introducing you to her
chinchilla
her rabbit cage her two cats some bird
and i swear to god i can't even i can't
even show you the size of this room here
i'm gonna pull this out but it's
literally the size of
my office like my you know my studio
kind of room here it's probably
i don't know 20 feet across and about 30
feet deep that was the size of the
entire apartment and it was like a zoo
in there
i totally agree with what ryan's saying
here if
her place smells like if it stinks like
a zoo you're going to have
problems i mean your clothes are going
to wreak there's going to be all kinds
of
fur on everything it just gets messy
women that are trying to
replace i don't know if they're trying
to replace it but i feel like they're
trying to replace
um children with small animals
um you know there's a saying that if
it's a small animal if it's a small dog
then she's trying to replace
the fact that she doesn't have kids if
it's a big dog then she's trying to
replace the fact that she doesn't have a
man
usually the big you know scary dogs
right dobermans rotties german shepherds
stuff like that
and then the other point that he's
making here is can't stand dogs sleeping
on
the bed another check i dated waking up
in the morning
there's her dog's [ __ ]
like i'm talking three inches from my
face you're lying there on the bed
just waking up you know just kind of
doing this sort of thing you open up
your eyes and you're like oh
[ __ ] and this dog's [ __ ] is three
inches from my face
and it's like i don't understand why
you're sleeping
with an animal that when you take it to
the park it rolls around and others dog
[ __ ] and eats it like again i like
animals
but there's a line you gotta draw in the
sand where
you can't allow certain things to happen
is this a big train wreck you know
am i am i making a mountain out of a
mole hill here
probably not but like i'd like to tell
you guys is you want to
not invite crazy into your life
chick's like swapping spit with her dog
or her cat
uh after it's been licking its butthole
or sleeping on the bed and there's like
feces everywhere you got problems with
that man you got like you know
the fur in the mouth and all that
somebody say
cat juggling we're not even gonna get to
the cat thing right now there's a super
chat here he says i just dropped 46
20 today on a second cat who needed
surgery for swallowing a plastic
mat piece thankfully i have pet
insurance that pays
90 percent i don't know listen i'm not a
big fan of cats
it's it's always these crazy cat lady
you know toxic feminist chicks that look
feminine that you
you know you go over and they have like
a cat collection it's
it's usually not just one it's usually
multiple of them
girls you know girls with dogs can be a
bit of an epidemic usually small ones
that they like to dress up and put
sweaters on
and carry around in bags and stuff like
that i don't know i'm not into it
if i'm going to get another dog i want a
dog that looks like you can rip off your
arm
and beat you with it right roddy
doberman
belgian malinois german shepherd problem
with those things is you need a lot of
land because you want them outside right
here i don't know we'll get to that when
i get to that i'll
i'll probably have another dog at some
point but again it's going to be one of
those types of dogs on some little fufu
dog
and then when they talk to them what is
up with the way women talk to dogs
huh here i'm gonna grab the link so you
guys can call in tonight
uh copied it clipboard post
call in and ask a question all right
i'll copy and paste this and kind of
spam it in the chat as we go here
i wanted to talk about the way that
women talk to dogs
the unhealthy way copy all right so if
you have a question tonight on tonight's
topic
you know disagree with something i'm
talking about here that's fine you come
in it's open
everybody men women young old uh i'm
gonna be doing q a
for a total amount of about 60 to 90
minutes and i have another show i have
to do
after this privately so what always
happens is you guys will will all pile
in towards the end and then i've got
like a dozen of you waiting to come on
and ask a question and it's like
sorry guys you left it too late so come
in now
anyway links in the chat come on in so
talking to dogs
like i understand talking to your child
i understand talking to even your
toddler to try to encourage it to
recognize your voice
to engage it in in in in something right
like you want an acknowledgement
but dogs are never going to get to the
point where they're going to respond
i remember you know this girl with the
dog with the [ __ ] in front of the
face of three inches in front of the
face
you know when you're sleeping when you
wake up in the morning she talked to
this thing like it was
uh not even a child it was like um
i don't know like a challenged child
almost
it's like you know just let it walk i'm
sure like it's an animal
these things were were like bred from
wolves at one point
i'm sure it can find its way across a
couple of stones when it's walking
towards us here
and then you know her family's like oh
you know this is her most endearing
quality you know
no it's really annoying actually is what
it is they don't understand
cats are just yeah look at this comment
here from jessie
cats are all entitled little c's for
real would never date a cat lady
say honestly don't just don't don't
don't get into anything
long term where women have these
unhealthy relationships with animals
where they're putting them in picture
frames on their desk uh
on santa claus lap dressing some ugly
christmas sweater
where they talk to them like you know
they're like children save yourself
a nightmare save yourself a headache
you